- [Instructor] Let's talk a little bit
about animal communication.
And, in general,
communication is one party
giving information to
another party somehow,
and it doesn't even have to be one to one.
It could be one person
giving, or one animal,
if we're talking about
animal communication,
giving information to many other animals.
And communication doesn't even
just have to happen between animals.
A plant can actually
communicate to an animal
through it's appearance or by
releasing certain chemicals.
But we'll focus in this video
on animal communication.
And it's interesting because
even we humans are animals.
And the more that we think about this,
the more types of communication
we'll see around us,
and it'll be interesting to think about
why we do that communication
and how we do it.
So, let's think about the
types of animal communication.
So, we can think of visual,
visual communication.
Just me drawing a diagram like that
is a form of visual communications.
So, we can have things like pictures,
pictures,
diagrams,
writing.
Writing's interesting
because it's conveying
kind of thought ideas.
It is conveying information,
it is something you look at,
so I would put writing here.
Writing.
You have even more basic
types of visual communication,
even if we stick to human beings.
The most obvious one I can
think of is facial expressions.
If you see someone who
has a smile like that,
they seem very approachable.
It feels like, hey, they're communicating,
even if they're not
consciously doing it, that,
"Hey, you can approach me, I'm friendly.
"Why don't you come talk
to me or we can hang out."
While if someone looks like this,
where they're kind of glaring,
where someone looks like
this, then you might say,
"Okay, this person doesn't look like
"they wanna be bothered right now.
"Maybe I'm not interested in
messing with that person."
And when you think about
facial expressions,
it's very fundamental for us human beings,
but why do we view this one
on the left as more friendly
and this one on the
right as more aggressive?
Well, it's through millions
of years of evolution
that these things just came about.
And we recognize kind
of an aggressive posture
or a friendly posture in our own species,
and in other species as well.
We know when a dog is
showing its teeth that,
okay, maybe I don't wanna
mess with it as much.
But if it's wagging it's tail,
okay, maybe it's in a friendly mood.
And similarly, it's not
just pictures and diagrams
and writing and facial expressions,
it could be body postures.
This is true of humans, it's
also true of other animals.
There's a whole TED talk
on these power poses,
these poses that you can take on
that can kind of establish your dominance
in an environment,
especially with other humans,
but it's probably not just
humans, also with other animals.
You'll also see, if you watch
these nature specials on TV,
animals striking certain poses
that exhibit their dominance in some way
or their position in some
type of a social hierarchy.
You also have animals,
just by the nature of their appearance,
that are communicating with other animals.
For example, there's
a lot of animals that,
by their coloration, they're
signalling to other animals
that, "Hey, it's probably
not a good idea to eat me."
For example, if this is
a frog right over here,
it's not that well-drawn of a frog,
but frogs are famous,
especially some of the ones
that have these vibrant colors,
that these are signals to
other potential predators
that, "Hey, you don't wanna eat me.
"I am poisonous.
"I will likely make you sick
"or even kill you if you eat me."
And the predators know that.
It could either be innate
through millions of years of evolution,
the ones that have learned
to avoid the colors
live on and pass their genes,
or it might some type of learned behavior,
that they tried to eat
one of these frogs once
and it made them really sick,
so they're gonna avoid it again.
As we know, visual isn't the
only type of communication.
In fact, normally, when we
talk about communications,
we often think of speech and
language or spoken language.
So, I'll write that down, speech.
Or let me write auditory.
Auditory communication.
And that could be speech,
this could be some type
of a bark, a dog barking,
saying, "Hey, stay away from
here; don't mess with me."
It could be a roar.
A lion's roar might be a way of saying,
"Hey, I am dominant here.
"Don't come here."
Or if you're a potential
mate, if you're a lioness,
saying, "Hey, look how nice my roar is.
"Wouldn't you want to come
and start a family with me?"
And it doesn't even have to be something
that kind of comes from your throat.
It could be beating of
the chest by a gorilla,
once again, to exert its
dominance in some way.
It could be some sound that an animal does
as a warning to other animals to run away
because it sees a predator.
So, we can keep thinking
of more and more examples
of each of these forms of communication.
Now, other forms of communication
that might be a little bit less
obvious, you have chemical.
Chemical communication.
So, what's a example of
chemical communication?
Well, we know that a lot
of animals, including dogs,
like to mark their territory with urine.
And when other animals come
by, especially other dogs,
they'll smell that urine
that might've been applied
to a tree someplace that says,
"Okay, this is some other dog's territory.
"I'm gonna go someplace else."
There's things like pheromones.
Let me write this down.
Pheromones.
Pheromones are chemical signals.
Even human emit pheromones
that are not necessarily consciously
but subconsciously sensed by other humans
and they can drive attraction
between those humans.
So, once again, it's chemical signals.
One animal is giving
information to another.
Now, another form of communication,
once again, not as obvious, is tactile.
Tactile communication.
And this could be a form of
kind of a nurturing touch
by the mother to communicate
to the child that it is safe.
It could be a warning.
You could imagine you're at a dinner party
and your significant other
kind of steps on your toe
when you find yourself saying
things that you shouldn't say.
That's all tactile communication.
"Hey, I'm giving you the information
"that you're starting
to talk about something
"that you're not supposed to talk about."
So, now that we've talked about
some of these general
forms of communication,
and I encourage you to just look around
either your own life or
just the animal world
and think about all the forms
of communication around you,
let's think about why
animals actually communicate,
including humans.
And we often think ourselves
as somehow beyond the natural world.
But when you really think about it,
most of our forms of communication
fall into the categories
we're about to talk about.
One category is coordinate group behavior.
Coordinate
group
behavior.
So, for example, if we are
about to go fight in a war,
there might be communication about,
well, how do we approach the enemy?
In what order do we do it?
It could be a team, where we make a plan,
either a visual or auditory plan somehow.
I don't know how you could
actually do a chemical plan,
but that would be interesting.
There's other things.
You could be caring for the young
as your main purpose for communication.
Care
for
young.
Once again, it could be
something like tactile
or even visual communication
or auditory communication
that makes the young feel nurtured
or you might be training them in some way.
In fact, even this video,
even the whole notion of Khan Academy,
it's a form of communication
that you could argue
is about coordinating
group behavior in some way,
helping to educate more people
so that they can
participate in a better way,
or you could view it
as caring for the young
or some combination.
But there's other reasons
why you communicate.
You could be defending territory.
Let me do this in a new color.
You could be defending,
defending
territory.
Obviously, something like
a no trespassing sign
does it very explicitly.
In fact, even a fence,
the existence of a fence
is a form of communication.
And obviously, in the animal world,
we can think of it all
the time with a bark
or with leaving your chemical
signature on a tree to say,
"Hey, don't come here.
"This is my territory."
And a very big role or
use of communication
that you'll see throughout
the animal world,
even in humans if you
really think about it,
is in finding a mate,
is in finding a mate.
You know, when someone goes
and buys that fancy sports car,
it's probably more than they need
just to get from point A to point B,
but it might signal
something to potential mates,
that, hey, I have a lot of earning power
or I'm flashy or whatever
else it might be.
And related to that is
you might wanna signal
some type of dominance.
And that dominance might
be for a potential mate
or it might be to defend your territory,
tell other people to step aside,
or that, hey, you should be the one
that's coordinating the group's behavior
(laughs) instead of someone else.